hi I'm Jan Nelson and I'm a program
manager in the windows and Windows Live
international team in Windows 8 we
wanted to make it really easy for you to
create your apps in multiple languages
to reach more markets my team has
created the multilingual app toolkit to
help you with that this cool simple set
of tools is a free download that
integrates into Visual Studio including
the Express Edition let me give you a
quick tour I'm here in the IDE of the
Visual Studio Express 2012 Windows 8
Edition which is a free download I have
already downloaded and installed the
multilingual app toolkit from the dev
centre this toolkit extends Visual
Studio making it easy to add
multi-language support let's open a
sample app called woof now let's go to
the Tools menu and enable the
multilingual app toolkit there I'm going
to add a second language to the project
so select the project menu then add
translation languages this brings up a
list of all windows supported languages
I'm going to select German for this demo
here we go you can see we add a folder
called multilingual resources this is
where we will provide all language file
management for you now you see we have
added a file called German XLF under the
multilingual resources folder this file
is based on an industry standard X Lift
schema to assure your resources will be
available to any translation source you
choose ok let's build the project which
will populate that German XLF file with
the english source strings in
preparation for translation we are
opening the X live file in the included
multilingual app toolkit editor ok you
see how we have the English in both the
source and the translation columns to
translate the file just type over the
translation version and save it it's
that simple
don't know any German that's ok we've
created a link to the Microsoft
translator service let's use that now
and get some great German suggestions
for the app I'm going to translate all
from the service and there we go the
file is completely translated with
suggested text I'll just close and save
this file
I had previously added German to my list
of preferred languages let me move that
up now as the main display language
there okay we can see that the German
XLF file has the translation suggestions
in it let's rebuild the solution and run
it cool as you can see we have created a
multilingual app and a few simple steps
it's now ready for a German language
expert to review the suggestions and
then you're ready to release to the
Windows Store it's just that easy to
summarize the multilingual app toolkit
makes adding and managing translations
easier for WinRT apps the benefits are
that you can quickly expand your
customer base and markets with added
languages you can focus on development
in the source language while the toolkit
provides multilingual resource support
and more thank you we hope you find the
multilingual
app toolkit a powerful companion to your
app building